oui tout ça ça se passe
quelque part dans l'espace
sur une boule qui roule dans l'ain
fini
tout ça ça se passe quelque part
dans l'espace sur une boule
qui roule dans l'ain
[Musique]
sogetel
on se bat tera
car guy
fqu
or
oh
on est tous
[Musique]
solidaires
souhaitez-moi
caries
là
et
autres choux
tout ça ça se passe quelque part dans
l'espace
sur nous
[Musique]
faire une samba sans tristesse c'était
mais une femme qui ne seraient que bell
ce sont les propres paroles de vinicius
de moraes poète et diplomate autour de
cette chanson et comme il le disait
lui-même le blanc le cul noir du goisil
j'en connais que la chanson incommode
d'autres pouilly ce n'est rien qu'une
borne de d'autres qui en profitent sans
l'aimer
moi je l'aimais j'ai parcouru le monde
en cherchant ses racines et vagabonde
aujourd'hui pour trouver les plus
profonds de ces la samba chansons qu'il
faut chanter
on m'a dit qu'elle venait de baghlia
qu'elle doit son rythme et sa poésie ya
des siècles de danse et de toula
mais quel que soit le sentiment qu'elle
excelle
elle est blanche de forme de rim blanche
de former et de rim est les [ __ ] bien
[ __ ] dans son coeur
alors grande première ça m'a pris 20 ans
pour avoir une version japonaise
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ta moi j'ai un peu lâché die
m
le cheminot
coco rocha
au soleil tati non
m'hamed alger
les
dans son cas elle
m
dans son coeur
[Musique]
ça va
pour être sûr de ne rien rater de nos
latitudes abonnez vous y mettez un peu
de bleu